the tourism industry has been especially
hit hard by the corona virus outbreak in
Thailand that's not just having an
impact on people working in that sector
but animals as well
thousands of captive elephants there
face starvation with venues ordered to
shut down many elephant camp owners find
themselves with no income and are
struggling to feed their animals
sometimes nothing can beat a good bath
these elephants might even be enjoying
the absence of visitors only a few
months ago Meza elephant camp in
Thailand's northern province Chiang Mai
was still brimming with tourists day
after day the elephants were taking
visitors on rides and entertaining them
with their ball control now as the
nationwide shutdown has left camps like
Meza without tourist dollars owners are
struggling to keep their animals fed one
elephant can eat up to 200 kilos a day
with 78 elephants MYSA is one of the
biggest camps in the country every month
it spends 1 million Thai Baht roughly
28,000 euros on fodder alone I'm very
very worried when you have like you own
one elephant 2 elephants 3 elephants or
even 5 elephants you it life is easier
for you at home you know you just find
them some food it's it less problem than
what I have
I mean I'm blinging 15 tonnes a day of
food at least to my elephant 78
elephants although her savings are
hemorrhaging the owner says she can't
lay off her ma hoots
nor set any elephant free as the animals
would be unable to fend for themselves
in the wild they have been looking after
by human we keep them food how many
times a day and we take them for bath
how many times a day and they are so
used to and they rely on each other
with crowds of visitors only a distant
memory the camp is now appealing for
donations to appeal to a broader base
the owner even decided to revamp the
park and said she would no longer use
her elephants for controversial
practices like carrying tourists or
performing tricks once we can open a
week you know could keep the camp and
children the life of the elephants at
Mesa elephant camp will be much better
for the elephants at least the world
after the corona virus might be a better
place